[Music]
we've watched the justice league come
together but that's only the beginning
of warner brothers plans for dc
domination
what do fans have to look forward to
over the next half a decade or so
let's take a look at the upcoming dc
movies that are going to blow
everyone away 2017's wonder woman was
the first dceu
effort to be widely embraced by fans and
critics alike and its sequel
the succinctly titled wonder woman 1984
will see diana taking on new challenges
during the era of yuppies
originally scheduled for a november 2019
release the flick was pushed back to
late summer 2020 and then again to
october
in addition to gal gadot reprising her
role the sequel is cast kristen wiig
as frequent wonder woman nemesis cheetah
and pedro pascal as maxwell lord who in
the comics is a villainous telepath
interestingly chris pine is also back as
steve trevor despite his character
meeting his end in the first film
patty jenkins has also returned to the
director's chair working from a
screenplay she co-wrote with comics
legend jeff
johns and dave callahan the story will
reportedly center around
magical artifacts one of which curses
wig's character and causes her
transformation into cheetah
and one of which brings trevor back to
life
see how it all goes down when the movie
takes flight on october 2nd
2020. you know what i'm ready to go
despite
introducing margot robbie's harley quinn
2016 suicide squad was considered to be
one of the dceu's more disappointing
early efforts with a wildly inconsistent
tone a final battle
bogged down by poor cgi and a poorly
received turn by jared leto as the joker
but it did pretty well at the box office
and during writer director
james gunn's temporary firing from
marvel's guardians of the galaxy
franchise dc struck while the iron was
hot securing him to mastermind a soft
reboot of the property
this time titled the suicide squad
it's not a total redo though gunn has
retained key players from the first film
such as robbie as harley quinn
joel kinnaman as rick flagg and viola
davis as amanda waller
and built his own stellar cast of new
characters around
them they include david de small chin as
polka dot man
steve agee as king shark daniela
melchior
as ratcatcher aka ratcatcher 2
john cena as peacemaker idris elba as
bloodsport
and saturday night live alum pete
davidson as blackguard
principal photography has already
wrapped on the flick and although it was
a tough shoot for gunn who lost his
father near the beginning and his
beloved dog near the end the filmmaker
still took to social media to call the
experience the most fulfilling time he's
ever had making a movie
plot details have been kept firmly under
wraps but this is a james gun joint
we're pretty sure it's going to be a
good time
join in on the fun when the film hits
theaters on august 6
2021. fans have been waiting a long
long time to get a glimpse of robert
pattinson in action
as the dark knight in the batman and at
dc's virtual fandom convention in august
2020 they finally got
their wish writer director matt reeves
who had previously promised that his
film would be a dark noirish work
focusing on the early days of bat's
crime fighting career
dropped a dark brooding trailer that
felt remarkably satisfying
considering that only about a quarter of
the film had been shot when it was
pieced together
the spot focused heavily on geoffrey
wright's jim gordon as he works on a
case involving a mysterious party with a
seeming grudge against the caped
crusader
this is paul dano's riddler of whom we
also got a brief glimpse
there's also zoe kravitz's catwoman who
appears to have her own clandestine
agenda
most significantly we were treated to
the site of pattinson's bruce wayne in
full costume
both working with gordon and beating the
ever-loving crap out of a thug on a dark
gotham street
i'm vengeance pattinson looks every bit
as intense and
batty as we'd hoped and a final shot of
wayne removing his mask to reveal his
haunted
makeup smudged eyes has us more
convinced than ever that reeves hired
the right actor
of course there's room for more than one
batman in the dc universe but
bat fans have to be pleased with how the
batman is shaping up ahead of its
october 1st 2021 release date
2017's justice league should have been
one of the biggest films of all time
but instead it became the lowest
grossing entry in the dc
extended universe to date and most fans
placed the blame
squarely on one man avengers director
joss whedon who took over and
completely overhauled the project when
original writer director zack snyder was
forced to depart midway through
production due to a family tragedy
fans lobbied for the release of snyder's
cut of the film for years
and next year they'll get it that's when
hbo max will debut
zack snyder's justice league which
viewers will have the option to watch
either as
a four-part mini-series or as a
four-hour feature sometime in 2021
snyder has already teased much of the
goodness to come a more fully formed arc
for superman the restoration of cyborg
as the movie's narrative heart
a new look for villain steppenwolf the
appearance of his boss
darkseid and a totally revamped third
act to name a few of those goodies
most importantly though snyder has sworn
that his version of justice league will
contain not
a single frame shot by whedon who by
some accounts re-shot
up to 90 of the movie after he took over
yeah and it's not like a competition you
know
well it it is a competition but you know
it's not like a macho um
measuring thing the teaser trailer that
snyder dropped at fandome
scored to the strains of leonard cohen's
hallelujah has us pretty much convinced
that zack snyder's justice league will
be the version of the movie that fans
deserve
and if it's as rapturously received as
we think it will be justice league 2
could even be in the cards
dwayne the rock johnson has been keen to
play shazam nemesis and anti-hero black
adam on the big screen for years
but ever since a solo flick featuring
the character was officially confirmed
way back in january 2017 details have
been rather slight
that all changed at dc fandom where mr
the rock presented some short video
clips featuring concept art for the film
revealing that the movie will stick
close to the characters comic origins
and that we can expect some
absolutely scintillating characters from
dc comics to show up
arguably the biggest revelation from the
panel is that the black adam movie will
introduce the justice society to the
dceu
featuring the team as a band of heroes
who are seemingly intent on helping adam
achieve his as
yet undefined goals but they reportedly
fail to realize that the insanely
powerful anti-hero might not want their
help
or consider what he might do to them if
they get in his way
appearing in the film will be iconic dc
characters hawkman
dr fate cyclone and adam smasher the
last of whom will be played by noah
centeno
perhaps known for his work in the
netflix romantic comedy to all the boys
i've loved before
after years of waiting we've never been
closer to the black adam movie becoming
a reality
we'll keep you posted on all the details
in the lead up to the movie's release on
december 22nd 2021
having gained plenty of superheroing
experience during the events of his 2019
solo vehicle young billy batson still
has a long way to go until he's ready to
take on black adam in the upcoming
sequel titled shazam
fury of the gods of course he may have a
little help
you'll recall that at the conclusion of
shazam batson was able to defeat dr
savannah by sharing his powers with his
foster family
transforming them into shazam-like
heroes who will presumably have a
significant role to play in the sequel
the movie's mid-credit stinger reveal
that savannah while currently imprisoned
is still a threat especially after he
teams up with that scene's cute little
talking caterpillar mr mind
a well a space worm from venus who is a
heck of a lot more dangerous than that
descriptor might make him sound
batson will need all the help he can get
with black adam in the picture although
there's always the possibility that the
anti-hero will lean towards his hero
side by the end of the movie
and end up assisting batson and family
against the forces of evil
shazam was a heck of a lot of fun but we
all know that superhero sequels tend to
go darker
it stands to reason then that young
billy is going to have some growing up
to do when the sequel lands on november
4th
2022. long-awaited solo film for the
flash has been cooking since long before
the character made his first cameo
appearance in 2016's batman vs superman
dawn of justice
the list of writers and directors to
have signed on to and then departed the
project is extensive but since the film
has been taken over by director andy
muschetti it seems to have finally found
itself on solid ground
not only that it's now shaping up to be
nothing less than the key to how warner
brothers and dc entertainment will
approach their entire movie universe
going forward
as we've long suspected the flick will
reportedly take its narrative cues from
the iconic flashpoint storyline
and as miller's scarlet speedster skips
across different realities he'll
potentially accomplish
the seemingly impossible feat of uniting
every dc
property into one complex multiverse
miller's barry allen already met up with
grant gustin's aeroverse version of the
character in the cw's crisis on
infinite earth's event an unprecedented
collision between the movie and tv
properties
what the hell is this i'm asking myself
the same question literally
according to recent casting developments
the flash solo movie will reportedly get
even crazier with the crossovers
not only did ben affleck unexpectedly
agree to reprise his role as the bruce
wayne that miller's flash knows and
admires but michael keaton will also
return as the version of the dark knight
we saw in 1989's batman and 1992's
batman returns
i'm batman
somehow we get the feeling that there
will be many many more appearances by
different live-action versions of dc
characters when it arrives on june 3rd
2022
screenwriter christina hodson who
previously penned the script for birds
of prey
all but confirmed as much at fandom
saying the cinematic multiverse is going
to be born out of this movie
it's born out of barry's story this
movie
by opening that door that flashpoint did
in the comics
all of these stories and characters can
start to collide
after justice league was met with a
deflated critical and commercial
response
any plans for a sequel were immediately
shuffled off to the back burner but that
doesn't mean that the powers that be
won't revisit the possibility for a
sequel if zack snyder's justice league
cut totally blows people away
if it does it just so happens that the
filmmaker has confirmed he originally
had a five film arc in mind which
included man of steel
batman vs superman dawn of justice
justice league and two sequels
if the retooled justice league does well
it's possible that some of those plans
could be revisited in the future
snyder has teased that as he originally
envisioned justice league 2 would have
seen our heroes taking the fight to dark
side on the planet apocalypse only to
suffer
a crushing loss the third film would
have seen the team returning to an earth
taken over by darkseid for their final
stand which would have involved the
flash creating a new timeline
well that was fun while it didn't last
it's too soon to know just how zack
snyder's justice league will be received
or how it will affect the road map for
the dc
extended universe as a whole moving
forward but it's safe to say that even
now
a justice league sequel looks a heck of
a lot more likely than it did even a
year ago
who knows where things have happened
justice league dark a potential feature
film based on the team that includes
such horror themed characters as john
constantine
zatanna and dead man has been in various
stages of development for an
unreasonably long time the great
guillermo del toro was attached to write
and direct as long ago as 2012
with the project being passed off to
edge of tomorrow's doug lyman in 2016.
after nearly a decade of no real
movement on the film fans were ready to
give up
that is until j.j abrams and his bad
robot production company stepped in to
save the day
in january 2020 it was announced that
bad robot will begin developing both
feature film and television projects
based on the property
warner brothers bringing on its hired
guns to rescue justice league dark is a
pretty strong indication that the studio
was never willing to let it die on the
vine
but at this point we're still not sure
what shape it'll take
and how long it'll take to get from the
writer's room to
in front of our faces also unknown what
team members will be involved
and whether or not the movie and or tv
series will tie in with the larger dceu
the idea of a feature film based on the
near unstoppable alien bounty hunter
lobo has been kicking around even before
the dceu's inception
with the guy richie directed version
discussed as far back as 2009 but later
scrapped
the project was revived as part of the
dceu slate in 2016
with san andreas and rampage director
brad payton set to helm from a script by
jason fuchs who contributed to the
screenplay for wonder woman and has also
been tapped to pen the minecraft video
game adaptation
it was rumored in early 2018 that none
other than michael bay was being eyed to
take the reigns and fuchs was still
reported to be working on the script as
is becoming a theme with the dceu
however the television side of things
has threatened to intervene
the second season of the sci-fi series
krypton features irish actor emmett j
scanlon taking on the role of lobo
leading some observers to speculate that
the characters feature film prospects
had dimmed
but there's been no official word so a
starring vehicle for the ultra violent
baddie could still be in the cards
once again the name of the game is wait
and see but if there's one thing we know
about lobo
it's that he never quits we thought we
did deliver him to it
[Music]
dc nabbed an oscar-winning legend for
their planned blackhawk film
steven spielberg who has taken home
three academy awards over his expansive
career will produce and likely direct a
film
based on blackhawk the enigmatic leader
of an international squadron of heroic
pilots who take on the nazis during
world war ii
the blackhawk character debuted in
1941's military comics number one
and was originally published by quality
comics before dc acquired it in 1956.
the character headlined a number of
best-selling comics in the 1940s
his world war ii background makes him a
great fit for spielberg who earned an
oscar and a number of other accolades
for his work directing the world war ii
based drama saving private ryan
he's reportedly bringing on indiana
jones and the crystal skull and jurassic
park writer david capp to pen the script
the future of the dceu's version of the
man of steel may be a bit up in the air
but one project that warner brothers is
reportedly high on is a starring
cinematic vehicle for his cousin cara
aka supergirl the character is enjoying
a high profile
thanks to the success of her tv series
set within the cw's aeroverse
and with the mcu's captain marvel having
arrived in 2019
the time seems right for the dceu to
introduce its own awesomely powered
female lead
little is known about the in development
project other than its screenwriter or
new zeal who penned 22 jump street as
well as the cloverfield paradox
the rumor mill has suggested that the
project could be set in the 70s in an
alternate timeline which sees cara
arrive to earth before her cousin
in order to set the film version of the
character apart from her tv incarnation
uzil has been at work on the script
since august 2018
so more details are sure to surface
sooner rather than later
what's the hurry
oh uh i'm with her check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite dc comics tv shows and movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you